You’ve almost certainly heard of MrBeast
— the 15th-largest YouTube channel by subscriber
count, made famous for doing extreme stunts.
When you see a MrBeast thumbnail, your first
thought is “There’s no way that’s real”.
There’s no way he actually gave a random
fan 40 cars.
There’s no way he actually bought a private
island,
Or planted 20 million trees.
If the internet has taught us anything, it’s:
don’t believe what you see.
Today, if you really were the one-millionth
visitor, you’d never know.
And yet, Jimmy Donaldson actually follows
through.
It’s honest clickbait, in a way that brings
back some of that early internet magic.
And in December, MrBeast did it again.
This time, by opening “MrBeast Burger”
— an actual restaurant where he handed out
free stacks of cash, Apple products, and,
yes, even a few burgers.
At the end of the video, viewers at home were
told they too could order a burger from one
of its 300 locations around the country.
Residents of towns as small as Evanston, Wyoming,
Population: 11,000, and Topsham, Maine, Population:
8,000, were surprised to find they too had
a local MrBeast Burger location.
The app was so popular, in fact, that it crashed
on that first day.
2 months later, over a million burgers had
been sold.
Now, MrBeast had the unique advantage of not
needing to spend a dime on marketing, which
might make this whole concept look like just
another influencer brand or publicity stunt.
But the most fascinating thing about MrBeast
Burger is the fact that it’s actually not
unique.
The way he opened 300 locations in only a
matter of months is the same way tens of thousands
of restaurants have stayed alive during the
pandemic, and a sign of where the restaurant
industry might be headed.
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and Nebula — where
you can watch the extended version of this
video.
No industry has been left untouched by the
pandemic.
But some have been forced to adapt more than
others.
While airlines were handed over $25 billion
in direct grants,
Small, local restaurants were left to fend
for themselves.
According to the National Restaurant Association,
$131 billion in sales were lost in just the
first five months of the pandemic alone.
Tragic as these circumstances were, they unintentionally
created the optimal conditions for a kind
of restaurant revolution.
Just as residents of New York City, LA, and
the Bay Area found themselves paying insane
rent with no access to the city they loved
and decided to take their money elsewhere,
restaurant owners soon came to that same realization.
They were still paying for the best real estate,
but, who, on the other side of a delivery
app, would notice if they moved across town?
And why stop there?
If customers never see inside the restaurant,
why pay for decorations, bathrooms, even signs
or tables?
That’s the basic premise behind what are
called “Cloud”, “Virtual”, “Dark”,
or “Ghost” Kitchens — somewhat ambiguous
terms for restaurants that don’t exist — at
least, not in the way we typically think of
them.
If you’ve ordered food delivery in the past
few years, and if the name of the restaurant
sounded a bit strange or unfamiliar, there’s
a decent chance you’ve already ordered from
one.
That’s because they aren’t entirely new.
Restaurants and food trucks have long been
able to rent “Commissary kitchens”, as
they’re known in the industry, to prepare
their food.
In recent times, however, and especially as
a response to the pandemic, restaurants have
found clever ways of taking this concept further.
One company, called “Reef Technology”,
for example, owns thousands of parking lots
across the country, which, of course, have
mostly sat empty.
To make up for lost revenue, it placed delivery-only
kitchen trailers in over 90 of its parking
lots, with recipes licensed from other restaurants.
Kroger, the country’s largest grocery chain,
did something similar by launching ghost kitchens
inside several of its stores.
Red Robin, Applebee’s, Chipotle, and Wendy’s,
to name just a few, also now operate delivery-only
locations.
Other restaurants stayed put but found new
ways to extract value from their fixed assets:
One of the biggest problems with restaurants,
in general, is that, for the most part, people
only eat during certain times of the day,
which means equipment, staff, and valuable
real estate sit unused for most of the 24-hour
day.
But nothing says they have to.
In the same way that AirBnB and Turo allow
individuals to make extra money from the time
they’re not using their home or car, many
restaurants now rent out their unused kitchen
time — which is how MrBeast pulled off MrBeast
Burger.
Your delivery driver will never see a MrBeast
sign.
Instead, they might be directed to a Bravo!
Italian Kitchen or Heroes Grill — real restaurants
whose kitchens have been hired by MrBeast
to produce his burgers using his recipes.
Guy Fieri also partnered with existing restaurants
to create 130 “Flavortown Kitchens”.
Another way for restaurants to make some extra
cash is by launching their own ghost kitchens.
A Mexican restaurant, for example, might launch
a delivery-only brand of Japanese food operating
out of the same kitchen, without any of its
customers knowing the difference.
You can even buy a ghost kitchen franchise
package.
For an up-front fee of $2,000, Chicago-based
“Wow Bao” will send you all the training
and equipment you need to sell its Asian food
out of your restaurant.
In fact, some have turned this into a feature.
Since multiple brands are cooked from the
same kitchen, they allow you to mix-and-match
cuisines for the same delivery fee.
So, for example, you could order some Tacos,
Sushi, and Bubble Tea all at the same time.
Usually, though, customers have no idea where
their food comes from.
Last year, for instance, a woman in Philadelphia
ordered pizza from what she believed to be
a locally-owned restaurant.
When it arrived, it tasted a bit familiar,
and not in a good way.
After doing some digging, she discovered this
“local” restaurant was actually Chuck
E. Cheese, using a fictional name on Grubhub.
It’s reminiscent of the white-label industry
on Amazon — where sellers buy, repackage,
and resell products under different brand
names.
For better or worse, this is the next frontier
in the industry — the Amazon-ification of
food.
Kitchens are slowly becoming anonymous warehouses.
You don’t know or care where your packages
come from, and increasingly neither do we
know or care where our food does.
At least, that’s the hope of companies like
CloudKitchens — the WeWork for restaurants,
funded with a $400 million investment by Saudi
Arabia’s sovereign-wealth fund.
The company starts by shopping around for
cheap, distressed properties — dying bowling
alleys, auto repair shops, and warehouses.
Within each of these buildings, it constructs
tiny 200 square foot kitchen “cubicles”
— which chefs can rent on a monthly basis.
These shared spaces contain everything a delivery-only
restaurant needs — grills, sinks, WiFi,
electricity, dishwashers, and so on.
Some might argue this takes away all the fun
of owning and operating a restaurant, but
there are also advantages.
Think about it this way:
There are good chefs and there are good business
people.
Some people are both, but not all.
That means, right now we’re missing out
on a lot of good food simply because some
good chefs don’t have good business skills.
Services like CloudKitchens lower the barrier
to entry, which moves the two circles closer
together.
The parallels between CloudKitchens and Silicon
Valley are no coincidence.
The man behind CloudKitchens is none other
than Travis Kalanick — former CEO of Uber,
before he was forced to “resign” following
a long string of scandals.
The question is: Why restaurants?
For all his tech-bro antics and reprehensible
behavior, no-one doubts Kalanick’s strategic
business mind.
And yet, the restaurant industry is famously
low margin and high risk.
Food is not software — there are very few
overnight successes, and there are natural,
physical limits on growth.
There’s a reason, in other words, none of
the world’s largest companies are involved
in food.
And why is loud, flashy, outspoken Kalanick,
hiding from the spotlight, making sure CloudKitchens
keeps a low media profile?
It would seem Kalanick is quietly biding his
time, waiting to launch a revolution of the
restaurant industry.
CloudKitchens wants to become the Amazon of
food — and, if anyone could pull it off,
it’s probably the man behind Uber.
This is where I explain Kalanick’s vision
for the future of food, and why he might just
be on to something, in the extended version
of this video on Nebula.
Just about every other PolyMatter video has
an extra-long, extended version.
In Part 1 of China’s Reckoning, for example,
I explained why the U.S. is not headed for
the same demographic collapse as China, despite
having a similar fertility rate.
Nebula is the streaming site I helped create
to give a home to more experimental, long-form,
and special videos, like Sam from Wendover’s
Trivia Show, Joe Scott’s Mysteries of the
Human Body, and Hbomberguy’s breakdown of
the True Detective intro.
There are no ads, videos are available early,
and you can watch entirely exclusive original
content.
We’ve partnered with CuriosityStream — home
to great documentaries on technology, history,
and science — like this one about why China
has one last remaining steam train — so
that you can get it and Nebula for less than
$15 a year.
Sign up with the link in the description and
watch the extended version of this video over
on Nebula.